hello I'm Ashley Vance a writer at
Bloomberg Businessweek and you are here
to see a chat with Peter Beck the CEO of
rocket lab who's kind enough to join us
from New Zealand and obviously from a
from the rocket Factory that I've been
to before thanks for thanks for joining
us Pete thanks Ashley
I think we must be catching you pretty
early in the morning 8 o'clock or so I
had a clock is not early in the morning
o clock is early in the morning so I'm
sure we have a lot of space buffs on
here but you know for people who are not
space but off so I was just gonna do a
little bit of the back story I got how I
heard about you and met you the first
time and and I think it was around yeah
I think it was like 2016 I mean I you
know I've been following the space
industry and and I'd been hearing about
rocket lab but then you know I started
to hear that whose crazy guy in New
Zealand - launching a rocket and and so
I went down there for hello world the TV
show we make and you were actually the
first episode we ever ever shot so you
were kind to put up with us but yeah I
remember is 2016 you were in a different
factory and there was you guys had I
think three Rockets kind of ready to go
and and since 2016 you guys have gone on
is this tear I mean there's tons of
companies trying to launch these small
cheap rockets and and to get lots of
stuff to space and you're really the
only ones who have been able to make it
and launch successfully so far I think
you're up to about 12 successful
launches correct here we just listed the
the 11th just before the lockdown okay
and so so you guys have you carry
satellites the space and and you're on
this mission to how to bring down the
cost of rockets and to be able to launch
just you know most of the big launchers
go about once a month then you guys want
to get every three days and maybe every
day yeah I mean that the tiger right now
is to to get to one one every month and
one every two weeks this year and
continue to drive down there down the
pace in in freeing will increase the
frequency and drive down the cost per
the
yeah okay so that kind of sets the stage
a little bit and then I just wanted to
use this as an opportunity for people to
get to know you a little bit better and
to know the company better but and I
don't want to make this too virus heavy
or anything but obviously this this is
the reality how I think we've all seen
the reports about what's we going on in
New Zealand that you guys have had a
very strict lockdown that you've kind of
tamp down the virus so you know what is
this done for an industry like the
aerospace industry have you been able to
operate during all this yeah so I mean
for us obviously we had to shut down the
entire factory in productions but you
know rocket lab people are very
resourceful people so we took this
opportunity to do a lot of a lot of the
work that you know we've often wanted to
do but just move ahead you know time in
the production schedule to do so I would
say that the team has been really really
productive down here in New Zealand we
have a very big program right now which
is the NASA mission to the moon so that
is a very big project for us so that
project got a lot of attention which was
really great to move that forward
quickly and you know we were able to you
know a lot of them you know a lot of the
company was able to be really productive
on their way through and then you know
some some of the teams took took various
equipment home and and we had we had the
stiff who who leads our harness group
building harnesses at her house and the
test team you know took home equipment
so it's very very not even a virus can
stamp out rocket lab the team was was
very resourceful and were able to make
good use of it but we certainly you know
we won't be be launching again here till
the end of the month and you know that
certainly you know inhibit ability to
launch which is which is tough but as
you can see behind me there's a you know
there's a whole bunch of rockets all
stacked up so yeah I'll do it ready to
ready to go
I'll give you props for the the
background on
on our live events I think you wins so I
know I'm sorry well so the next launch
that you mentioned I mean that you you
guys you along with SpaceX have a
private private launch facilities and
and so you have a pad in New Zealand on
the North Island on the East Coast in
sort of like the most beautiful place
you could ever imagine and then you're
building another another launch facility
on the east coast of the United States
and you have another pad coming in the
New Zealand site as well and so so how
how have things been affected with the
construction at the u.s. site well the
u.s. thoughts complete so we actually we
rolled the rocket out you know just
before lockdown and in it sites complete
ready to go so we just you know the
final the final thing there is
certification for from from NASA for a
FPS system at autonomous flight
termination system that we fly out of
that range and we're good to go
so they're paired to complete there's a
rocket sitting there already there's
another another vehicle sitting down at
their demo here and the the second pair
that Mar here will be will be complete
by the end of the year so we'll have
three operational compares by by the end
of the year and currently have f2 so yep
any of any of capability and what do you
you know so you it's very
capital-intensive business there's a bit
there's a bit of a race going on in that
there's there's I think there's like
dozens of small rocket companies
obviously only kind of like a handful of
that you might consider you know more
legitimate than others and you know
funding is tougher to come by right now
you guys have this huge head start in
terms of already completing so many
launches so you know I mean but it was
it's a very exciting time for the new
space industry because we had all this
money pour in we had tons of rock yeah
tons of satellite companies what you
know we've already seen one web a big
satellite company file for bankruptcy as
they were not able to raise funds so
what do you like for the as far as the
new space industry goes how damaging do
you think this this pandemic
we'll be I think it's fair to say that
the new space industry has had a long
warm summer and there's been a lot of
capital flow and a lot of good times I
think probably you know November last
year or there abouts the last half half
of last year I really felt that things
were getting out of control because the
the kind of things that were being
invested and had you know had very you
know tenets of business planes attached
to them and it's you know very very far
looking which is great don't get me
wrong I mean it's great to know to
really look and decently down the road
but the end of the day you know Beach
capital still requires a return at some
point in time so you saw some business
plans that were pretty skeptical and
stuff get funded that that you know even
I was sort of okay good on them that's
awesome
and I guess I'm I'm slightly a slightly
biased because I remember the days of
you know walking around the valley
trying to raise capital and and
everybody you're looking super
cross-eyed at me it's like well you know
what's this guy trying to do you know
and it sort of became the norm and I
think we saw a tremendous amount of
capital flow into small launch and in
you know it's just not sustainable so
unfortunately there is going to be a bit
of consolidation but you know with with
any crisis you know it's a good
opportunity to to leverage it and you
know there's a lot of really good
entrepreneurs and space companies and
technologies that I think you know will
will combine and build bigger entities
and do do good things so I'm pretty
confident that you know I guess I take a
much longer term view than just like a
you know one or two year view I think
you know the overall temperature for the
it will be will be just fine but it's
going to be a pretty rough road here in
the next their needs you know 12 to 18
months because capital was going to be
non-existent well especially on as the
satellite side too because obviously you
guys need customers to fly and
there were I think several dozen
satellite companies that had appeared
and and even though it doesn't take
quite as much money as Rockets it takes
a lot of money yeah yeah and we had
always previously divorced ourselves
from from accounting for the mega
constellations and any of their business
plans because the moment you you start
to build a business plan around an
immediate constellation or build build a
business plan around somebody else's
startup that's when it gets pretty
pretty dodgy so you know we've never
taken into account or proclaim that
we're going to fly 300 rockets a week or
you know some so some of the numbers are
average is crazy
so you know we're we're very much you
know a bespoke service for customers
that they care about you know on orbit
on time you know exactly in the right
place when they need it rather rather
than you know I we're you know we're
more of a I guess like a limousine
service then and then a Costco so the
you know in I just want to so people are
sending in questions which is great I
sort of had like a path of questions I
want to take but but I'm you know just
just I want to throw a couple at you
that are coming in just while we're here
so I you know there was a lot of people
asking about today you you've focused on
putting satellites into low-earth orbit
you mentioned you mentioned that you've
got you know a lunar mission could you I
want you to do two things can you
describe the lunar mission and then and
then we get a lot we're getting a lot of
questions about rocket labs ambitions
through the solar system and what kind
of things you guys would do so first
first the lunar mission well I I'll
actually answer that round the other way
because it makes more sense okay if you
don't mind so I guess you know people
look at rocket late as a rocket company
and really it's probably a failure on my
behalf my behalf calling it rocket lab
because there's never intended just to
be rock company
but rocket was the first piece of the
building block that we needed to solve
there's no point in in solving the
satellites if you can get them there so
you know we're very much a Space Systems
business you know we've started will
spacecraft hints the reason you know
everyone's seen that we won their that
mission you know to the moon Vanessa and
although that's you know that it's a
high energy upper stage it's actually
asked our photon satellite platform
because we stay in orbit for a very long
time and we do lots of maneuvers and
I'll talk about that in a moment but but
that you know we're we're building
satellites flat out we just acquired a
satellite company so like components
companies Sinclair interplanetary we
have contracts with governments to
manage their satellites on orbit and
we've really we really try to provide an
indian solution so you know if you have
a sensor or a capability that you're
trying to create just come to us and we
can build a spacecraft platform we can
launch it we can operate it we have a
you know a unique agreement with case
set the ground stations you know provide
us to be able to really provide you know
a global network of ground link and you
know ultimately what we're trying to do
here is just make it easier to get
innovation and ideas on orbit and the
rocket pieces is one important piece
that it's just one piece of that so you
know if you look at our kick stage I'm
surprised that more people didn't pick
it up way sooner because if you look at
a kick stage it's just a satellite you
know it does its put a solar panel on
another satellite so it was very
purposeful that we did that so you know
the the you know they're increment from
a kick stage to a satellite it's very
small so you know really we've been in
you know every every over the last 10
missions we've actually operated our own
satellite and all but every time we fly
so so I think you know I think you know
we've been building that for quite some
time and you know the the the lunar
mission is is really just a high-energy
photon so you know we take all the
components are in a photon and we've
upgraded the curry engine to be what's
called hyper curry now
to a much much more high-performance
engine for this you know these types of
missions and that gives us a platform to
you know to do things like take 37 kgs
to the moon
and similar masses to Venus and then
this nest to Mars so you know it's it's
it's a if you look at the photon
satellite platform you went into the
spectrum you've got like a cook stage
which is a very basic satellite through
to the other end of the spectrum you
have a super high energy mega complex in
the planetary probe so we really try and
cover the full game but with that
capability and so in I mean I saw you
jump it on to some of the Twitter
questions you know about this like you
were talking about Venus so you know
what given that okay so with the big
rockets the massive rockets you know
we've got guys wanting to colonize Mars
and take ya you know tens of thousands
of tons of equipment and and and you
know build habitats and everything so
with with a smaller rocket I mean we if
you get to Venus what kind of things
would you be able to do well you have
way about 25 kgs of science instrument
mass so you have to remember that the
photon platform you know power supplied
thermal supplied converse of light even
supplied so the pure scientific max so
25 kgs you know might not sound like
much but actually you know you can do a
lot the best spectrometers multispectral
images you know there's a tremendous
amount of instrument that you can you
know you can put on there but I guess
the most exciting and liberating thing
about this is that if you wanted to go
to the meanest if you wanted to go to
Venus be prepared to write you know to
300 million dollar check minimum with
with a you know an electron or a photon
platform we reckon we can get to Venus
for twenty million dollars or less right
so as far as you know opening I mean
kind of the the door for planetary
science it's it's just enormous and you
know you can do half a dozen missions or
more dozen missions for the same prices
as as one mission and do them quickly
you know Venus 2023 Venus's close so you
know we're gonna do some missions of
Venus that needs to be 2023 so that's
quick and I know I've asked you this
question before I'm not sure I always
believe your answer so I'm gonna ask you
again in public and put you on the spot
I mean you've always said from the
beginning of rocket lab you know part of
your part of your dream your mission was
was to get the prices down get the
frequency up make it where where we can
just do a lot more stuff in space and
create like a prop you know a proper
economy so I totally get that you're
heading on that direction obviously you
have other people like Elon and maybe
Jeff Bezos who like we've said you know
they're they dream of colonies and and
taking the human species sort of off
earth and so so I've always asked I mean
I've always been curious I mean like
when you when you channel you deep into
your your childhood or your kind of
sci-fi fantasies I mean is it does it
end with kind of this burst of economic
and scientific activity or what you know
what is what's like what is your
ultimate dream what are you trying to
achieve with with rocket lab yeah it's a
great question
and in as you point out you know a space
vehicle company gives you an ability to
do wonderful sense of humanity and going
to other planets you know and Inhumans
stepping foot on moon and other planets
it's awesome I'm in the front row
cheering but I guess I take the view
that you know it's slightly more
clinical and engineering viewers is that
you know space is a place to build
infrastructure the infrastructure that
we currently have in space is is
absolutely critical in life changing for
so many industries you know you take GPS
since it covers everything from from
Maps through to national security
through to Oberer and tender like is
covers a it's a huge spectrum of things
that that include that that provides to
everybody down on earth and I just
believe that if you can make it easy and
affordable to build lots of
infrastructure and space then lots of
wonderful things are going to happen
down on earth and if
if you you know you've been to the to
the factory probably not this one I've
been that's why sorry do ya you remember
as you open the main door you know the
first thing you read is we we go to
space to improve life on earth and and
you know space is one of those things
we're there oh there are no borders and
when you put up a spacecraft
you know you provide services to all of
the countries around the planet every 90
minutes so as far as infrastructure that
has the ability to touch the entire
population of the planet you know that
is that is space so that is you know
that that's that's my prime driver is I
think we we can improve a lot on Earth
through leveraging the things that space
has to offer no in saying that yep and
so it's only it's not it's not like I
don't have my own little own little bit
asurs myself and and you know Venus's is
clearly one of them but I think as you
know as a company in what we can
actually you know the mark that we can
leave in history in the market we can
leave on humanity will be will be
building infrastructure and all that so
everybody else is talking mugs and
you're you're claiming venus then well
it's not claiming a planet I've always
been interested in Venus and you know
the the photon platform you know the
original work was done by Richard hunter
who was a PhD student that that we hired
and you know it's his riches job was see
how far you can get with using an
electron doing some crazy or orbital
mechanics and really that the the
impetus behind it was I want to get to
things and in in I guess you know Mars
Mars is received a lot of press because
Mars can use captures the public's
imagination because you can step foot on
Mars and you can put a footprint on Mars
and that is awesome so everybody can you
know there's very visceral let's that's
exciting Venus you know buddy is either
going to step foot on Venus you know the
atmosphere the atmosphere 400 something
degrees C 90 atmospheres afresh you're
not you know not standing on the surface
of things however for me if
look out into the solar system there's
kind of three three universally
understood places in our solar system
where life may exist and one of them is
Venus in the way I look at it is is this
is humanity's greatest treasure hunt
like the biggest question you know we
are we alone and then when I say that I
mean any life and there's a really
interesting position in Venus's
atmosphere where it's just sort of down
in a sweet zone where it's one
atmospheric equipment to one it
atmospheric pressures of Earth it's not
a particularly nice place it's very
acidic and horrible but moderately
temperate and there's some weird stuff
going on there with some UV absorbing
things that nobody really quite
understands and it's it's at least in
principle some extremophiles from earth
it should be able to live there so
you've got this this this weird cloud
that whizzers around that absorbs UV
radiation UV light you've also got an
environment which in theory could
support some kind of life microbial
bacterial life so we need to we need to
sort that out we need to go there and
you know I just like yeah I just want to
have it have a crack at there and seen a
couple of you know atmospheric entering
probes see see what we can find
no that's cool okay I haven't heard you
I haven't heard you got a riff on that
before and then in any other are you
like a secret cingulate aryan trying to
spread humankind's intelligence through
the universe or anything anything you
know way off in the sci-fi realm no I I
just I just quite like to know if we're
if we're unique or not yeah I mean is is
is life because if we can find life and
Venus then you have to assume that's
pretty prevalent okay I'm just peeking
at some of the questions we've got some
hard core space ones I'm gonna save
those you know like like technical
questions I'm gonna save those for a
little bit there's a lot of people they
are you know
in New Zealand that I'm sure I don't
know what the situation is in the US but
so people who want to watch the the
launches and have some kind of viewing
platform you know I know ma has a bit of
a tough place to get to but so what are
you what are you guys thinking moving
forward around how people can watch the
launches so at LC 2 in Virginia this is
a really great viewing area there so and
so there will be the best view on launch
black bar the challenge with the mayor
here Peninsula is is such a remote piece
of a piece of land you know it's
sticking out there's there's not really
any good places to build viewing areas
and it's all you know private land so
you know we obviously least a bit of
lane that we're on but you know we don't
we don't have the rights to to go and
build greenstein's and stuff it's not a
sheep farm right yeah yeah yeah
so we're working a working sheep farm
yeah yeah keep yeah it's great for us
keeps all the grass down but but but
nevertheless you know I think I think we
haven't done anything there we're kind
of hoping that some entrepreneurial
spirit will come along and and and go
and do that off their own back but you
know the night launches are great to
watch you can you can see those from
from the beach and from the towns but
it's just a really challenging place to
to build a viewing area and you know it
is still you know it's the only private
orbital launch site in the world so
normally these are government lands and
you know government has the ability to
do whatever they want on them but this
is all privately yeah and then the we
had obviously there's a lot of interest
so at first you guys were not really at
least publicly looking at reusing
rockets and I mean I think you were
actually if I remember right I mean were
you were you not into that idea and then
and then lately you've been you've
actually started running running tests
where I mean and tell me if I describe
it poorly but you would you would catch
the rocket with a helicopter as it kind
of re-enters after doing its job
delivering a payload into orbit and and
so we have questions around
and I know you guys are public about
silhouettes like that people want to
know sort of where you're at when the
first one will be and yeah and then
maybe if you could go I know you've
discussed it a bit before but tell me
you know what what change your mind yes
I was I was oh I was not not very
excited about trying to reuse electron
and you know the way we've designed it
was to be disposable for the pure fact
that you know in order to to reuse you
know first stage and and I would say
quote unquote the more traditional way
which is you know positive landing
you take a small launch when you make it
very big so there wasn't really the
point and so I kind of dismissed the
concept because whatever concept we come
up with it has to be you know the mess
penalty has to be a maxim that sort of
ten to fifteen percent of the total
stage or payload reduction so that's
very very hard to do I mean you know
from propulsive landing is sort of
thirty percent or more of the payload
capacity goes to do that so so I kind of
written it off but it was once we
started flying and we started looking at
the data and you know reviewing the same
data and actually how the stage was
heating or not heating in this case it
sort of became more obvious and then
really what what what you know cooked it
out for me it was standing here and
looking out into the factory and
thinking well if I want a double
production that's that's a really hard
thing to you know continue to do if I
wanted an easy way to double production
would may be to just get one back so so
we started really digging into there and
broke the program up into three main
milestones as one can really into a
stage which is by far the hardest piece
of the whole program is getting it
through the atmosphere in one piece the
second part is you know can can we can
we slow it down and get it under some
parachutes and then third pieces you
know if we get it under parachutes can
we actually indeed scoop it out of the
sky before it lands in the sea so we've
successfully demonstrated to the three
elements we've reentered two stages
successfully
and that was there was a huge milestone
you know we were able to we bought those
stages and as hot as fast educating so
basically we just we did nothing to slow
them down we just pour them into the
into the atmosphere and they both
survived and we had strong temperature
Lincoln and a relatively healthy stage
until they impacted to see it just under
900 climbers an hour so that was super
good and then the the second piece we've
just demonstrated is is collecting it
out of the sky because we don't you know
we don't want it to splash it down in
the water it's not a good but a good
place and we recently successfully
demonstrated that as well so the last
pieces can we get under a shoot and
that's scheduled flight Stephen tina's
is the one that we're shooting for that
so that vehicle is behind me coming down
the production line and you've been
you've actually been learning to fly a
helicopter
are you are you allowed to trip to try
and catch this thing I'm not good enough
good enough for that no no I can I can
you know Eppley flies to the launch site
and back but I am that that is NYX level
skill okay I do not possess I thought
this was part of the master plan maybe
it does does help justify owning a
helicopter Nate okay it's just a real
quick one from someone kind of to our
earlier conversation is like how far out
can electron put a payload in the solar
system that's a good question so we did
do some trajectories we called it at the
Grand Tour which was like a giant
billion year heliocentric tour of the
solar system you know in all that in
order to get out to someone like Jupiter
there's a lot of a lot more energy so
you know I would say we're limited in to
kind of the you know that the near the
near cousins so you know any asteroid
that's cruising by moon Mars Venus I
think we can get something to mercury as
well yeah okay and then there's another
one here I think I might know the answer
to this one but you know okay so I've
been hanging out with like just
every rocket startup you can imagine and
in this part of the world you know I not
trying to set up a softball here
anything I think electron is seen is
just about like the perfectly engineered
rocket for what you guys were trying to
do I mean I know you put a lot of
obviously effort and smarts into it the
somebody's asking though you know is
that the perfect rocket for the company
you know are there ever plans I don't
know to do something different to go
bigger I know you've got a lot on your
plate at the moment so but but that's
the question you know it's fair enough I
think you know is when we when we looked
at electron and where we thought the
market opportunity was you know
naturally I'm biased but I think we have
we're right in the sweet spot because
anything much larger than electron you
no longer can really affordably offer a
dedicated service because the cost just
becomes too high and you end up becoming
a right here and now you're competing
with as a rideshare vehicle you're
competing with SpaceX PSLV failure in
all those vehicles it becomes very very
cluttered and challenging market any
smaller than electron you're not useful
to be able to lift you know useful
messes and you don't have enough energy
to lift useful messes so as I look at
electron I think I think you know it's
it's the right place to be I worry when
I see launch vehicles that can lift you
know sort of a one-ton class launch
vehicle because you're just going head
to head with SpaceX in a falcon 9 on a
rideshare and that's a tough place to be
as well as he did with PSLV and a lot of
other really low cost ride share options
so you know our goal here is to provide
dedicated service like you know we're
not the bus if you if you want to if you
don't care where you picked up you don't
care where you dropped off and you're on
someone else's timetable which is a bus
take the bus if if you really care about
where you want to go when you want to go
you take the uber and we are the uber
and you wouldn't expect to pay the same
for an uber as you do a bus ticket yeah
so the
you kind of go larger than that then you
just in this in this neither region of
super you know rideshare and the
rideshare marketers is it's crazy
because you've got like the PSLV vehicle
which is you know subsidized by the
Indian government so you're now trying
to compete as a commercial company
against the government subsidized
vehicle it's not not a great place to be
in my opinion so okay I do have a right
share question though and so for people
who aren't aren't space nerds or
enthusiasts you know so basically on
these very large rockets which might
carry one or two kind of bust car-sized
satellites there's there's all these
little pockets of space around where you
can fit smaller satellites and so you
kind of you hitch a ride whereas whereas
you guys take a satellite exactly where
it wants to go and the rocket is you
know it's built for that mission but so
you know SpaceX I noticed I mean Elon
used to be fairly dismissive or I guess
maybe even like nonchalant about the the
small rocket market for a long time sort
of least when I would chat with there me
to sort of be like I don't even follow
what's going on there and then and then
one day last year he space like to
dramatically cut the prices for their
rideshare program which seems like a
fairly since you guys are the only it
was small rocket launch think it's see
it seemed it seemed targeted so you I
mean what do you what do you make of
SpaceX's moves there and yeah I mean you
know I know you just went through this a
bit but does that to that disrupt some
business or your strategy at all I love
a bit of competition punch-ups great
isn't it so so yes but ironically the
the you know the customers that we see
the most coming to us our customers that
have been promised a ride on a ride to
your vehicle that doesn't fly and it
said it was going to fly and and you
know the first basics Raj here was going
to fly and March so you know there's
there's the thing was with with
rideshares is that you know you have to
wait until everybody's
on the bus until the bus leaves so you
know you have in like I say that the
customers that are coming to us there is
a cost to sitting on the shelf if you if
you have a satellite company and you
need to generate revenue and you sit on
the shelf for a year it's far cheaper to
just buy a dedicated electron launch
vehicle and you are in charge of the
entire mission and you get to go exactly
you need to go when you need to go so
you know we see we see a lot of
customers actually you know punching out
of rideshare and buying dedicated
launchers sure we're more expensive
that's that's a fact we you can't you
can't not be and in going that way but I
think Raj here is what she has a really
important part of the market and the
industry because you know there are a
lot of spacecrafts they just need tech
demos they just need to get out and it's
been really the enabler I would say to
to enable the small satellite industry
to grow so I don't want to I don't want
to be down on right here because I think
it's I think it's it's been instrumental
in in growing the industry and we do our
own righteous as well you know we ride
share a bunch of small cute pets along
with micro and do it so I think it's
it's you know it's it's a really
important part yeah and competing with
Elon is always interesting have you been
have you been following his Twitter feed
the last couple weeks
no I'm yeah so I'm not big on social
media I'm good
so I tweaked the odd thing that I think
is interesting but I'm certainly not
sitting there you know following a bunch
what a bunch of other people were doing
we've you know we're going to get a
mission to the moon so that is all
consuming there's hard well he's been
quite active I'm just picking up the
questions I'm gonna take a couple more
questions in a second there were there
were a couple they were asking is I
think you have wireless headphones on if
it's not too weird
can you swivel out maybe and and just
because your factory is amazing it's
like the [ __ ] you can like perform
surgery in there
I know it's far away but what can you
tell us obviously those are rocket
bodies down there and and what can you
just give us a little play-by-play on
the factory yeah so in in the very end
of the factory behind the flags as Rosa
the robot so basically they're so
basically raw material comes in here is
a raw tube goes into Rosie the robot and
every piece of machining marking
trimming it's all done in that machine
and it sticks out of the machine and you
can see just out pass Rosie there's that
first that tube here so so that tube is
is you know it steps across into these
these various booths and the first booth
is is like some coding boot the second
booth is a soundproof booth so that's
where we do all the any noisy operations
because having a clean factory is
critically important and clean is not
just spotlessly clean it's it's also
from a noise perspective you can't
concentrate building rocket engines and
a noise so basically it goes along and
then it it shoots into these into these
you know on that side there's another
one as well these noise soundproof rooms
where any any you know noisy operations
are completed then kind of step across
the factory and this line here this line
here is yes this line here is the final
production line so actually there's one
in front of that you probably can't see
so there's a bunch of rockets here as
well so and this is where these get
shipped out and to the to the launch
site and there and you know how has how
the speeds changed and how long it takes
you to make a rocket from like 2016 to
today well every 30 days is one roll off
the lawn off the production line now so
some some parts like composite steamer
are down to one rocket every 18 days so
you know the the rest of this year you
know the team is striving for one rocket
every 18 days so we continue to you know
to push hard to you know increase
production but yeah
very short and there's a bunch of
questions they kind of play into that
I'm gonna try to like condense a couple
of them and it's a it's a difficult
question to answer but you know just as
part of knowing you and and getting into
rockets I've been reading a lot of
rocket history and you know if you go
back if you go back almost like exactly
a hundred years you had Robert Goddard
in the United States and some folks in
in Russia and Germany that we're trying
to build roughly kind of stuff that they
that you're trying to build and and over
that span of a hundred years hardly
anyone has been successful at doing it
you know the SpaceX made the Falcon one
and we've got some other sort of similar
things but it's it's incredibly hard to
do y-you know so this is kind of a
two-part question I guess is we've got
this century of knowledge clearly we
know how to build giant rockets there's
people who've done this before who have
experience they can go to these rocket
startups but like you know why is it so
hard to do and and and how you know to
the I know a lot goes into this so but
to the extent that you guys did figure
this out kind of had you know how did
you figure it out yeah so the way I
think about building a rocket company is
imagine yourself running through a maze
at night and at every dead-enders
there's a guy with a shotgun they will
shoot you so you have to live to run you
have to run quickly with you know very
little eyesight or information and then
but not run too quickly because you need
to poke your head around the corner
carefully to make sure you don't make
the wrong decisions because you know
within a rocket company a wrong decision
one wrong decision can be in so you know
blow up a launch pad blow up an engine
test especially early on there's there's
just no recovery and also going down a
technology path that is also wrong there
is no recovery
there's no time to back out and go up
screw that engine up design up we'd
better go back
can start again with a new engine design
there's just there's just no no mistakes
of you just can't make mistakes and then
so so knowing when to poke your head
around the corner and go no there's a
guy there with a shotgun we need to turn
around and also having the courage to
continue down that thing that looks like
a dead end
because there's all it always looks
greener right you'll get halfway into an
engineering problem and your thing is
getting really hard maybe it would have
been easier to do that way and then you
forever just bounce around you know try
and never never actually draw to a
conclusion so so I think I think that's
part of it the other part of the magic
here is there's a curve right and you're
seeing a playing out now right there's a
curve where there's this kind of
interest analysis that you can do and
you can sit in there and just analyze
analyze analyze analyze and not build
anything there's the other end of the
spectrum where you can just build
something and just keep blowing it up
the and there's there's a curve where I
believe there's there's a suite spawned
a suite point of efficiency and right at
the top of that curve there is where if
you can get you know the experimental
bit right and the end of the analysis
that right we don't end up you know
churning on either end of that scale
then you can move move quickly and I
think that's what we've been able to do
well is do good experimental work
understand physics and fundamentals and
and you know we're the real grenades lie
and then also quickly always be a very
hard rich a hardware rich environment
where you know we test a lot and but
also we do the analysis in the research
up front up you know to make sure that
we're not running down a path which is
just fundamentally flawed so it's a it's
a real balance were you I mean were you
like are you a rocket his historian and
just just so people know I read like you
are a self-taught rocket engineer I mean
you didn't go to university and do like
a PhD in this you know you're this
world-class engineer who I know you know
as a kid was was building propellants
and fuels and all that so so obviously
at this from a very young age
had hands-on experience but like like
how much were you in to rocketry history
and how much you know were you or were
you not and how much did sort of that
past
inform your decision-making to find that
right spot to turn the corner well I
mean engineering is engineering at the
end of the day it doesn't really matter
if you're building a rocket or
Washington shaking or whatever it is I
mean you know engineering as engineering
and logic as logic so so I don't I don't
you know I don't think there's anything
nothing unique about you know about
building a rocket it's just that you
just can't make mistakes it's pretty
much pretty much it so you know I don't
know like I said I don't I don't think
there's anything getting particularly
unique there
and what about is I've always want to
ask you this I mean so you you were this
very passionate driven self-taught guy
and then you start rocket lab it's in a
country that has you know really uh sort
of like no aerospace industry and and
you know I've met a ton of people on
your team it's these very young a lot of
Kiwis a lot of Australians but people
who never had a chance to work on a
rocket before because you were the only
game in town so like what's your what's
your feeling now I'm sort of like
hands-on versus university trained
person how do you if you had to talk to
sort of young people who are watching
this and they really get into this
industry I mean what you know what would
you advise versus versus being an
apprentice and doing hands-on stuff or
or going to maybe even get a masters or
a PhD in aerospace engineering or
something or physics yeah well I mean
firstly be paid be passionate about the
thing you want to be in and I only do
the thing that you really want to want
to do my job is not a job I'm just just
having fun so if you can get to their
point then you know it's it's a it's a
you're likely to be successful and you
know so having you know really following
your passion I think is the first thing
and then just do lots of stuff you know
if when
you'd see these and you're trying to
fill a position you can get 100 CVS
they've all gone to great universities
they've all got great grades but the
person we will hire is the person who on
the weekend has built a lot of really
cool stuff and has has demonstrated that
they have a passion just beyond school
so and though they went out over someone
with better grades every time like
there's someone who is passionate
energetic and just wants to get stuff
done
we'll always went out and and you know
you can you can make up you know
knowledge in a lot of a lot of cases you
know for motivation alright I've got
many big philosophical questions but I'm
looking at the time let's go let's go
rapid fire to make make the people happy
and feel like I got their questions
answered so why why in this business do
we pick kerosene and liquid oxygen
instead of other fuels well for us I
mean it's just a it's a good well
understood easy to handle appellant
combination there you know choose what
you want to innovate in propellants just
weren't the place we want to do innovate
you you guys are pretty famous for being
3d printing a lot of stuff including
your engines and being kind of the first
to to do that are the engines 3d printed
in one fell swoop or components that are
put together there's large components
that that are generally still put
together and there's about three main
components that that are that are
assembled and then in all that all the
turbopump
and and you know transfer lines are all
stall with 3d printing you guys have
some pretty classic mission names like
it's a good time a little Flight of the
Conchords love and and so people are
enjoying your names is there any chance
the public may be able to name a mission
yeah yeah I mean we generally what we do
is we we have a new mission if it's a
dedicated ride we work with the customer
to come up with the name if it's it's
kind of got a few few folks on it we
just open it up to the staff and we have
kind of rolling
juster of names but sure I mean yeah we
can open it up to the public and we're
getting super rocket nerdy now we were
going to the electric turbo pump one
question was was you know kind of why
did you guys do that and why hadn't it
really been done before and then one
very technical question is there a
vibration reduction by using an electric
turbo pump versus a normal one yes so we
went down that road you know we felt
that if you if you distill apart a
rocket engine the most complex you know
complicated elements of the rocket
engine the turbo machinery so if you can
turn turbo machinery into essentially
software and have one moving part and no
no mess of thermal gradients or turbine
you know pre-burners and all that kind
of jazz it just makes it so much simpler
so so that was kind of the motivation
for doing that and you know there's
there's lots of wonderful things that
you get through the system like the
appellant utilization you know
infinitely variable throttle infinitely
variable are we afraid shows and things
like that so it's it's it's super good
from a vibration standpoint I mean you
don't have the combustion an empty mix
of a pre burner so you can you could
argue that it's it's in some respects
it's quieter but at the end of the day
you know the most the majority the
vibration is caused by the combustion
device and any any you know acoustic
mode you have your going on there so it
stood a little bit removed from that
from you know the pumping in mudslide
are there any plans for a European
specifically Scotland in this question
large sites or you know obviously you
guys have your hands full with New
Zealand in the US but but any any future
ambitions there yeah we took a good look
at actually they the Scotland range and
when we we did all the flight safety
against that range we really only popped
out with two trajectories we could even
fly and you know there's from a safety
perspective and those two trajectory
corridors weren't commercial corridors
so you know there like some weird
inclination that we couldn't sell so
so it really didn't make commercial
scenes for us and you know we're keeping
an eye on on the European market and the
one good thing is it doesn't take us
long to build a launchpad it was nine
months to build one in Virginia so at a
later date afters if there's an
opportunity here we think is worth it in
the team scheme pretty good at building
launch beds yeah yeah I got a question
not to put you too hardcore on the spot
but you know in a company here we go
well in a couple weeks
space legs might be my you know if
everything stays on track will be flying
to humans to the International Space
Station first time the US has been able
to do that in a long time it raised a
lot of questions about kind of like you
know even though this was very much done
in partnership with NASA not only NASA
money but but people and technology in
the will but you know raised a lot of
questions NASA's building its own large
rocket to do this kind of thing that's
been heavily delayed and cost a lot of
money I mean what do you think what do
you think we've got we've got you guys
we right we've got Blue Origin coming on
pretty strong what do you think the role
of NASA should be over the next 10 years
I mean should it evolve from from there
are spots where they're competing with a
pretty vibrant industry right now and
and so what do you know what would you
like to see NASA do over the next 10 20
years well I think Nessa's in in Jim
Bronstein he's well understands us
writers is the private industry do what
private industry does well and that
that's exactly why we've got this super
exciting you know commercial launch
astronauts I mean it was there was the
best thing they could do and you know we
have we have this really exciting
commercial mission to the moon so I
think I think they're you know I think
they're doing it exactly right right now
is you know engage in commercial
industry getting them to do the things
that rightly so this this day and age
you know we commercial industry should
be flying humans to the space station
and that's that's a completely
reasonable and doable thing and in NASA
can focus on the things that
that don't make commercial sense yet so
this is this is the role of governments
right is you know things that are
important either for the nation or for
humanity that this is where governments
you know governments can it can really
provide huge value things that you can
turn it back on
and actually you know make profitable
private industry should actually
absolutely do it and I think this is
where I think they've got it just right
right now is there anything like
philosophical that can be said about a
private space company getting to this
point especially in the middle of this
pretty grim time globally you know I
mean these are always seen as
inspirational events yeah so I mean I
don't know does it touch pull on your
heartstrings at all or really you know
what does it say to you the you know
hopefully everything goes fine but
assuming it does I just think it's
awesome I think it's I think it's
incredible and and Elon and the team of
SpaceX have just done just done a
wonderful job it's a beautiful looking
capsule it's it's it's just like because
I'm always in the front row cheering
anybody and especially especially a team
as they've just built a beautiful thing
and and done something really really
hard and I think this really cements a
new era in human spaceflight I think
there's no going back from here it's
just awesome
all right I'm only doing this to you
because there's three questions about it
have you have you studied the Iranian
and North Korean rockets and what do you
make about their orbital ambitions I'm
familiar with the vehicles yep and the
the you know leveraged Healey have you
leveraged off things like Scud missiles
and things like that so there's there's
a lot of scale up going on in there
look I think one of the one of the
responsibilities you know certainly we
when you create an orbital capability is
making sure you use it for good so you
know I
I'm like everybody else's is that you
know there's a there's a huge
responsibility that goes along with
developing this technology and you know
having having the wrong technology in
the wrong hands is it's not a it's not a
wonderful thing okay so we are about to
wrap up we're about to end and you know
I've known you for a while I've done
like a lot of research about rocket lab
and your background and stuff so maybe
if you don't mind riffing for just a
second especially for younger people who
are watching this I mean you were we
talked about it before you were a little
bit of a lone wolf to some degree
growing up you've ended up managing a
very large company at this point what
what's been like that the hardest lesson
you've learned and what sort of advice
would you impart to people you know who
want to go from becoming an engineer to
becoming a CEO of a real company I think
it's it's officially going out to
something that you believe in and it
ultimately is the thing you know I'm a
firm believer in going up to really big
problems because those small problems
the the Delta between solving a small
problem and big problem is not huge
especially in a business sense so go
after the really big really big problems
and you know just work hard I mean
there's there's no there's no there's no
magic here it's just you know the
passion that you want what you want to
do and and work hard and you know it's
pretty much just it probably not very
inspirational but it's it's the fact of
it all is that there's there's there's
no there's no kind of magic recipe here
or something I've done that nobody else
has done or some mint or anything it's
just you know I just I just think it's
critically important that we build
infrastructure and all but and go to
Venus and just
work hard like um yeah get stuff done no
just get stuff done I think that's it's
a great lesson and and I mean there's
just no especially in in rocketry
there's no cheat codes or anything like
that so there no no no no the the rocket
gods rule supreme the moment you taking
a shortcut you know about it yeah we'll
Pete thanks so much for doing this good
luck on your next launch and and you
know you know thanks for being so
generous with your time appreciate it
no problems thank station all right
cheers mate good luck cheers thanks